une briseuse de couple juif que ça y est
je ne comprendrai je vous dis non je
vous dis un mot vous me dites qui sait
une briseuse de couples gays markle non
plus tout à fait pas attendre et
réfléchir de préparer l'émission alors
les gens le savent pour valérie
trierweiler a pas faux mais ça valait le
royal mis sa santé non je risque de
coupure kaki saddam et auch alors c'est
en rapport avec quelqu'un que vous
connaissez très bien qui est animateur
sur cette chaîne mais on cherchait à
brioude oui chartaa brizolier william
leymergie magali berda non une briseuse
de couple
c'est vrai
mais ça sous-entend qu'elle est belle
[Applaudissements]
elle est très belle magali j'ai déjà
n'avait qu'à la semaine prochaine pour
vous dire si
c'est une chroniqueuse aux séries en
fait une animatrice très connu qui était
mariée à un animateur très connus de
cette chaîne flavie flament bravo flavie
flament
[Applaudissements]
c'est simon castel
l année prochaine on fait des jeux ça
et si on l'a compris mais on jouera la
finale à briouze de coupe c'est elle
mais qui a fait ses débuts
alors simon castellvi regarder le dessin
ça notre ami jordan de luxe que jean sa
mère
la première belle maman vous le voyez
toujours
je la vois j'ai dû je la revois de temps
en temps parce que je suis quand même
très proche de mon petit frère enzo les
rapports seront
nul n'est en rien je pense que au fond
de moi j'ai géré est toujours l'image de
la de la briseuse de couple le papa vous
avec les rapports avec benjamin avec mon
père c'est c'était compliqué le divorce
voilà le monde le sait il a pleuré plus
d'une fois sur les plateaux télé il n'a
pas été présent et voilà le problème de
mon père je pense aussi le le vrai sujet
c'est que mon père quand on partait en
vacances avec ses amis il n'y avait pas
de moments intimes aujourd'hui ça va
mieux avec lui on s'est beaucoup
rattraper mai mais un peu trop tard je
pense qu'on est à dix buts en dix neuf
ans quatre pattes ont fui
aulas jeu on lave le linge a lancé vous
alors oui il est vrai que jamais elle a
fait plusieurs interviews et se rattrape
oui dit qu'il a perdu beaucoup de temps
et n'a pas profité de ses enfants et
maintenant ils rattrapent le retard et
ça c'était très touchant je trouve pas
ce qu'elle aime beaucoup de femmes il a
une vie tumultueuse beaucoup de fait
beaucoup de carrières mêlant car c'est
vrai mais ça vous dérange pas ça qui les
attend comme ça sur mon coeur aucun
parent n'est parfait fin il ya un moment
où il faut faut savoir pardonner à ses
parents non je trouve que la balance et
un peu gabon c'est son choix mais c'est
dommage pour benjamin qui qui est plein
de repentance comme tu le dis dans ce
par l'oti benjamin ouvertement et oui ça
s'en vient mais a glissé une dynastie de
toute façon ils sont tous connus dans la
famille du plus jeune qui vient de
naître jusqu'au dernier le met de
l'allant pour dire mon père était un
mauvais père deuxième femme se sont
pardonnés tous les deux donc maintenant
ils peuvent encore
y chargeant bien non moi ça me touche
parce qu'on pût si c'est un peu trop
tard alors qu'on sait que benjamin fait
tout pour rattraper le temps perdu et
c'est et arrive à y arriver un tronc de
jean basset trop tard le mal est fait
donc on peut pas savoir sur moi je n'ai
pas vu comme ça justement été précisée
mais qui dit non parce qu'avec toute sa
bonhomie qu'on lui connaît et sait qu'il
aime c'est en france que tous les
chances que ça lui fait évidemment
d'entendre ça mais je crois que simon il
dit ils cherchaient par une carrière
j'en étais arrivé alors qu'on prenne les
deux armées et les deux enfants vous
avez vu là ce sont issus d'une première
mais revient à l'oreille valérie après
il ya eu la langue à longages eu deux
enfants ava et le dernier c'est un
grille l2 j'étais vraiment dernier avec
aurélie le dernier set en or or la maman
et gabriel le nom du bébé
c'est le jeu des 7 familles c'est
compliqué assez compliqué l'on appelait
fils des machins oui un poème c'est
qu'on risque de toujours lui poser un
petit peu les mêmes les mêmes questions
parce que simon castaldi pardon mais il
n'est pas célèbre pas célèbres comme son
papa donc quand on voit ce qu'ils
défilent chez jordan de luxe depuis le
début de l'année c'est en général plutôt
des têtes d'affiché c'est connu c'est
pas ça ce que j'ai à dire c'est qu'on va
toujours lui poser ces questions-là donc
forcément on va l'amener à déverser un
petit peu c'est évident sur la version
répondre ou d'autre chose ne va pas le
contraire alors moi je le dis et dieu
sait si j'ai de l'affection de base la
marge encore passer un week-end est qu
en normandie ce que je vous dis là je
lui dis à lui le problème c'est quand tu
te livre autant quand a plus de
barrières on va dire à l'antenne que tu
te livre que tu te mettes banques que tu
donnes tout pas forcément tu es un
exemple pour tes enfants qui vont faire
la même chose est-ce que c'est pas un
peu le problème aujourd'hui moi je vais
maintenant on dire j'étais un mauvais
père malsain et toutes ces familles si
c'est pas le lui par exemple match nul
aurait pu tout simplement dire aussi
simplement mes parents n'ont pas été
exemplaire quand j'étais petit
aujourd'hui j'ai pardonne c'est à dire
qu'en fait il peut se livrer mais c'est
que là il livre un discours qui
finalement est plutôt négatif pour son
père donc on peut pas décider pour lui
moi je suis entièrement d'accord avec
matthieu aron c'est vrai que ça me fait
de la peine pour benjamin rivière
plusieurs reprises ça va mieux avec une
nettement malgré on se dit bon bah ça va
me relancer la machine mais ce et
surtout qu'il vous en veut un peu
visiblement pas ce qu'il a dit que quand
ils partent en vacances partent avec ses
amis on allait aux maldives j'avais marc
olivier fogiel matthieu delormeau il n'y
avait pas de mouvement alors c'est là
que la voix qu'à mon avis et des petits
problèmes de boisson
alors que j'adore ce gars sont parfois
utiles si monfils et simon alors simon
sur ma vie je n'ai jamais foutu les
pieds aux maldives de masse et paris ne
suis jamais allé avec qui il avait fondé
il ya une autre star une sommité local
s'arrête avec plaisir je n'ai jamais mis
les pieds de ma vie au même si fillon
qui s'était pas pris le même mois ce qui
est ce qui me dérange un peu en réalité
c'est ce garçon sait que son seul rêve
dans la vie soit il n'a pas fait
d'études il n'a pas il n'a pas les toits
qu'il intéresse c'est de faire
globalement dans les pas de son père un
peu la même carte des visuels coiffer
les rênes et qu' ils n'auront déjà les
défauts du truc pas imminents lui ne la
prends rien fait en sorte
qu'il fait il fait la téléréalité et des
booking au vote de nos excuses aux noirs
et alors cette ago
marthe étonne pas que ton père soit pas
occupé de toi parce que tu vas être
pareil globalement
les mêmes tons beige et benoit la la
célébrité c'est une conséquence c'est
pas un objet hybride est bien chiant
c'est le jour où tu as compris ça ce
qu'a compris hanouna et jean il ya d'une
frappe sur ce plateau de très génial je
suis devenu riche parce que je ne visais
pas la richesse c'est s'avisait a même
donné les pleins de la tlpe chez eux
c'est déjà boîte de nuit et est
influencé par la droite et cette fois le
talent quoi penser quoi le talon de ces
gens là il va peut-être les 200 décrets
tôt comme aujourd'hui vous allez tous
commencé à quoi quoi entendre le nom de
cette personne elle retenir mais en vrai
c'est qui voilà bien c'est le fils de
joe magri et du coup le père jean pierre
castaldi et du coup on reproche à
benjamin d'avoir le faire de la télé
parce que son père était connu aussi
c'est pas pareil tu as de la
télécommande non ils commencent par les
anges et des booking enfin benoît bien
commencer par quelque chose moi j'ai
bien commencé par